[Music]
welcome back
to another awesome episode of the
careful boys we're extremely careful
here let's dance around careful
and we have a special guest today mr
kuno
the famous janal
famous from shangshi oh that's the whole
imdb shanghai
i mean that's the big yeah that's the
biggest thing did you how many lines did
you have in shanxi oh man
almost three or four
[Laughter]
i had i had a lot of like
these faces though
good reaction that was good yeah
actually uh fun fact the last shot of
the movie is my face
oh before the credits that's pretty cool
last night movie is me and stephanie sue
who's awesome also great sick we're
going like this
is that what is that what the audition
was you just had to
show us i'm surprised what did they make
you do for the audition uh they actually
have the full scene
that first scene which is a lot it is a
lot of it it is a lot of like
what do you go in knowing that's your
strength and you just can't wait to hit
them with it that i can make faces good
faces yeah
you're like i'm kind of in the motor not
to brag just wait you'll see man
they're really good
some auditions that you that didn't go
well and as you're walking out the door
you're like hang on can i just do one
can i vote for you was there like did
you shoot like a bunch and then it's all
cutting room for [ __ ] and then you go
see the movie like wow cool i'm uh when
i brought my [ __ ] entire family
you had like three monologues
yeah
i was actually yeah one of the main
characters and then they cut it uh no
wait shank she's that guy
mom i swear to god i was shane cheese
there was actually 20 rings uh i was the
other 10.
gotta read the whole storyline yeah too
many rings you know we're gonna do a
re-shoot with simu as a shank she just
for see what happens is it true that
sema wasn't wearing the jacket that was
all just a green suit and they put the
jacket and the jeans on them like cg
yeah he's cg his jacket and his regular
pants and his jeans yeah yeah and his
bandages jeans
she's wearing a green screen suit
i mean obviously i wasn't there for
those shoot days so
i wouldn't know you're busy shooting the
last scene and prepping for that one
yeah yeah well yeah i was shooting uh
shang tree too so oh
no
no it wasn't oh
uh but that sounds insane
sounds like a lot of work so it's such
an overkill but i heard not one piece of
denim touched his body not one square
inch of his body
white like he didn't want that wasn't
his i don't know religious reasons i
just pictured
that green suit with the
face showing
just from top to bottom
his hair too just to put a backpack on
him
but but why though is he like anti-denim
i draw i don't know i just read about a
[ __ ] article hollywood reporter yeah
so for um people who don't know uh this
isn't ritesh
but we did mention kunal when we were
talking to ritesh but we i had to bring
it up because we kept on talking about
kanawha while tesha's here and he
obviously does every movie with you
right yeah yeah we that's in our writer
we only
work together he's coming with me
a duo yeah yeah we're into i guess who
gets top billing like deal four lines we
trade off we'll pay it off yeah we trade
off we trade off in the last you guys
share the same trailer and then like
whenever one of you guys doesn't want to
do the line it's like you send the other
guy in yeah we're basically mary kate
and ashley
do you have do you have a good um
impression of ritesh oh no
he has one of you
he does
can you do him doing me didn't he do
could all like slightly like last time i
feel like he's racist bro i feel like he
did canal a little bit did you just
think he was me but then but then i
don't know if it was like a parody of
you because he just kept saying he was
so cool
he's like i'm calling i'm so cool
i do say that a lot
i do say that a lot that's pretty good i
will be listening for that today yeah
yeah
did you guys live together no we
practically did though practically just
like we all practically live together
because like their whole circle of
friends like they were always over like
there was always so you guys knew each
other from the dance world or like kind
of just like uci because you were close
with uh
lawrence right and then yeah and these
guys okay right actually uh i wanted to
take this moment on camera to formally
do something that i haven't done in like
10 years and i probably should have make
out with canal
i actually want to apologize to all this
is what i uh
this is what i did to you last time i
want to apologize to canal because there
was a point in my this is
real gay right now it's me being serious
okay okay
it was it was like 10 years ago right
before i was about to uh really take off
on my or try to have dances my career
right so i had quit my sales job when i
was in riverside and i moved back home
blah blah blah right so i was in this
place where i had like no money i was
like living at home blah blah blah with
that
uh and
i started couch crashing at lawrence's
right lawrence liverpool also was also
kept crashing at cools right you
remember that north hollywood yeah i
know yeah yeah okay so i was couch
crashing but you know that friend who's
like such a [ __ ] loser who doesn't
know when to stop couch crashing
and i'm talking like i i was i was i was
there when people would get home i was
there when they would leave for work and
you're like go have a good day at work
i'm such a good guy i'm like not
necessarily cleaning up after other
people i'm being respectful of myself
but you know i'm not doing extra yeah
and i remember there was a moment where
finally like they had to have like a a
mini meeting oh no and you know but
they're friends so they're trying to be
like
cool about it but they're like dude like
at the end of the day it's like this
[ __ ] bum needs to like pay rent or
something how long did you stay for i
was honestly i was probably like two
months
i'd say the max is a month matches a
month
yeah yeah that's like get on your
[ __ ] feet and figure [ __ ] out you
know dude i should have known you back
then i would have been like dude this is
what you do i'm like you right now right
yeah do you spread it out you can stay
for years and people won't even realize
wait what do you mean spread it out you
have many friends take your sheep and
then you go one tour here
one week's probably the max that's the
problem though all the friends were
living together never had many friends
isn't the problem
back to the point of the story i want to
thank you and apologize for that time
when i was bombed i'm now just a normal
bum that knows that you shouldn't do two
months you can only do a couple weeks at
a time so what did the talk like look
like you know when he went up in front
was it while you were sleeping on the
couch they were just on the dining table
they didn't include me in it
did i
tell you like hey lawrence had to tell
me oh lord said to tell me laura's such
a nice guy too right yeah so he's like
hey man like uh you know the guys we had
to have a meeting and uh
uh you're kind of staying here too long
was the thing that you needed to pay
rent or leave yeah so what got you into
this position where you had no money
you had no place to stay
and you enjoyed freeloading off your
friends
enjoyed
that had to be 2011.
oh okay so if it was 2011 that means uh
i just got laid off
from my old job
and and that was also that was a hard
year for me because i also broken up
with my ex-girlfriend at the time she
just needed comfort yeah so i i
was just lost and low
uh and then so when i decided to choose
dance as a career it was a very starving
artist kind of lifestyle so i also
picked up a sushi
waiting job with lawrence because
lawrence had worked there
[Applause]
with the turtles exactly so then because
i was working with him and that was in
la canada even though my home home where
my parents are at is in bournemouth park
and oc so there was no point of me
trying to like go from oc all the way to
la canada every day for my shift so i
would say in north hollywood which is
where they were living
and you know since lawrence was he was
training me at the sushi restaurant too
so it just made sense for me to stay
there but i totally over save money so
what'd you do after are you like okay
i'm gonna pay or did you did you oh yeah
i ended up uh paying for um
a couple weeks because one of the
roommates suey was like going do it he
went to go do something else so his bed
was available so i did that and i
obviously offered i felt really bad and
offered but the second he came back i
was just like i'm done i overstayed my
welcome and then i bounced good job yeah
and then i tried to get my [ __ ] together
and
finally i'm facing my friend after all
this time
um even though i've seen him in between
but yeah well let me just say now that
you bring this up uh i'm gonna take this
opportunity to say
i don't remember any of this
it was so built up in your head and
there was nothing to this man nothing
like barely here's here's the thing was
it tesh that was there is that yeah
he remembers more of the [ __ ] he took
back then yeah than this big thing that
you built up from
all this time here's the thing i i think
the reason why i don't really remember
this is because
you were probably like the fifth person
that did that
[Music]
like matt tayo did that at the weho
apartment and then ended up finagling
his way into a permanent roommate into
the yeah yeah i remember that and then
at in this weho apartment the first
place we lived in la there was six of us
in a three-bedroom apartment right
sounds like fun
but then people just kept getting added
like like laurence and tony were on a
bunk bed
these guys were like i'll remember that
26 years old in a bunk bed
but with layla the dog yeah with the dog
and then people just kept getting added
because they like similar situations or
something and so by the end of the year
we had 10 people living it's a hospital
yeah it was a hostile like just sleeping
on the floor on crescent heights right
yeah yeah
yeah i am loved you guys how come you
guys didn't get caught by your neighbors
or anything like that dude we had the
chillest neighbors of all time but they
were doing it too owners
that's how you know
probably but we also had these neighbors
below us that were an old couple they
were like a senior couple
but they were just the coolest people
like we would literally go downstairs
and run into them and be like hey sorry
about the noise cause like we'd have
parties and stuff and they'd go it's
okay you're young have fun and we were
like what's that today's video is
brought to you by feels
cbd is not about
what you feel it's about what you do not
feel such as stress pain anxiety
sleeplessness all this crazy [ __ ] i've
been liking fields you know why why
so i used to take it mainly at night
but now i started taking it during the
day and what i realized is sometimes
monday through friday i got so much work
on my mind on the weekend when i'm
trying to relax i'm still like glued to
work you ever been like that were you
like thinking about stuff you're like oh
man i need to relax and be with the
family but sometimes i feel like i'm not
really present because i might have too
much anxiety thinking about other things
i try jacking off it doesn't work as
good as feels yeah i can't just jack off
and then make me feel good when i play
with my son so it's easier if i take
fields take a couple drops under the
tongue relaxes me i'm more present less
stress less anxiety and it feels really
really good that's good you know what's
awesome about fields too is that like it
comes in this super discreet package it
shows up on your door
monthly subscription super discreet just
in case you guys don't want anybody else
to know how you feel yeah it's premium
cbd comes right to your door and they
have a customer hotline so if you're
like oh man it's my first time i'm kind
of scared can someone walk me through
this you can call them and you got to
hold me on the phone that'll walk you
through the whole process and if you
become a member they get to give you a
discount and you don't have to worry
about it anymore because it'll just come
regularly and it's super easy to use you
just put a few drops under your tongue
and you're just like
and then you know you could have an
unwind method like i do for my sleepless
nights i get so dang tossy and turny but
with the feels it just makes me feel all
good but the cool thing is there's no
hangover you know you just put a couple
of drops on your tongue
and then you can feel it in minutes and
then for me it just helps me relax and
goes straight to sleep so yeah it's
super helpful um check it out become a
member today go to fields.com off the
record to get 50 off your first order
plus free shipping that's f e a l s dot
com slash off the record to get 50 off
your first order plus free shipping
trust me you're gonna feel good if you
have problems sleeping or if you're
dealing with anxiety it's very helpful
it's premium cbd go to feels.com
off the record to get 50 off your first
order plus free shipping start feeling
better with feels what happened yeah
yeah
i mean they are living in there was also
a kyle duning there's also like a white
guy anytime you got a white guy though
it's like i feel like you're safe
it helps it does help
literally sometimes cops will pull up
and like like tell the white guy to open
the door all the minorities would go
[ __ ] hide in the rooms and just the
white guys would go out and we'd be good
i swear this happened a lot yes
yeah since the white guy's like oh [ __ ]
where's my sweater vest
my letterman jacket
very funny if you did that very funny if
you did that and then the cops are
[ __ ] chinese
or the white guy's like hey don't worry
we're just raping cheerleaders and like
okay
that's fine
that's normal [ __ ] whoa
see only the white guy can say that yeah
yeah yeah
that's what's going on yeah for sure
[Laughter]
it's not me putting my neck on a
guillotine every time i come here
wait so before
all of this you guys known each other in
in college
yeah yeah you guys went to uci yeah we
all went to college together so that
like how did that happen like you met
them too out there yeah well yeah we
actually went to uci i went to uci
wait you did you did too i didn't know
that i did but by the time uh i was
living in costa mesa i had already
dropped out to do dance [ __ ] oh okay
that's why
so so when we were like kicking it a lot
more you were already out of uci which
is why i never i didn't go to uci at the
same time as you i went way later i just
thought you [ __ ] played video games
that was it
i i would when i would go over to that
house i would always like just like
snoop in on ryan to see what he was
because he's like interesting he's an
interesting mother he's on yeah when he
talks
um but he would either be like playing
like this most random like jrpg
or he'd be like composing a symphony on
his [ __ ] keyboard like either or
insane my favorite story about ryan is
like it was it was like 2001 and the
worst thing that happened to him in 2001
is his final fantasy game ended weird
and that's and he cried it ended sadly
and that was and i cried he cried about
it in 2001 the same year as 9 11.
this motherfucker's crying about a
[ __ ] fantasy game dude it really was
it was the same year how dare you do
that he asked me was the last time i
cried and my mind instantly went to what
i beat final fantasy 10 in 2001 and he
goes oh same year's 911. okay and i was
like oh [ __ ] it was didn't even bring it
up yeah
loves those rpgs though wait what was
the weird ending oh not it was just a
very sad romantic ending oh
okay and he was like crying about it
devastating
he was pretty bummed
that's the last time i legitimately
cried it moved him now that hollywood
house through all the disasters this
country's been through
that's that hollywood house you guys
were all a part of was it like
everyone's trying to
pursue their lives and entertainment or
like what was it no not not yet right
um me and lawrence had just started
really going for it acting and stuff
yeah yeah in the noho one i had like
just booked my first commercial which is
like a wendy's commercial that's right
yeah where i had to like stuff my face
with
burgers and spit it into a bucket like
the spit bucket yeah why you couldn't
just eat it
well here's the thing we had to take
five bites every take
and so every time our mouth's full and
by the end there was three of us we went
through a hundred something burgers wow
that was like
insane were they delicious
no they're cold
they look so good in the back so the
front doesn't look good the back not at
all yeah the front never looks good
that's that's a hollywood secret i
learned that day was they call the
camera uh it's like the camera side and
so that that uh backside is perfectly
proportioned and looks great but on our
side it was like smashed into the
restaurant it's the restaurant version
yeah yeah just like bun didn't you want
to flip it upside down and eat it like
this
because it's cold because if it's hot
it'll like smoosh or the cheese will
melt in the cereal it's cold the lettuce
will turn all soft so it's all cold how
do they make the meat look like it's
glistening when it's cold they spray
stuff on it yeah they lube it up dude
how did those [ __ ] in the carl's
junior commercials do it oh yeah well
they're watching a car right yeah
they're watching the car how the [ __ ]
did they do and then they go
send in the [ __ ] you're the ketchups
yeah those are used to be bangers but it
was like very [ __ ] like it was always
very [ __ ] like and i like that i always
like that
there's another there's like a fluffer
who's on standby with like latex gloves
and they're like kind of like the
[ __ ] what there's an actual word for
the dude who's that blonde they always
use
yeahologist or some [ __ ] uh
for the carson result they always use
this same blonde for the carl's jr one i
think it was just different blondes but
they all look the same to you
that's what it was they're all like
really famous it was like paris hilton
it was everybody hot everybody
was doing it i swear to god
weren't you writing comedy before you
started doing commercials i remember you
writing a lot of [ __ ] well when we moved
into weho me and lawrence were like
let's
make a youtube channel and so studio is
64 68 oh yeah we have four studios for
comedy we uh yeah somehow uh
tricked joe and bart into doing a video
at one point i wonder if it's like
still up there but it was that's right
it was like that weird detective thing
and we were we filmed it at your
apartment right yeah holy crap what was
that like in 2010 or some [ __ ] yeah it
had to be that's 10 years ago dude
12 years ago brother did you all um go
to the same classes and stuff at uci
like how did the actors and dancers all
like get into the same friend group spa
spot yeah
yeah so there's this thing called spot
which is student parent orientation
program that sounds wack
it does sound good
dude hearing people talk about spot
because like i came way later and
whenever it would just get mentioned
everyone in the room would act like it
was some like
glorious thing they would go oh spock
yes what i'm like what the [ __ ] is that
because what parents get involved by
college look you gotta understand right
first of all it it sounds exactly as
wack as i'm gonna describe it
it is that i'm not gonna lie it just
sounds like student teacher conference
student parent
orientation program so what happens is
when you're an incoming freshman to go
to like uci in this instance right um
when you go there before curriculum
starts you go there during the summer to
get your orientation so you're going
there you and usually you're staying
there for the weekend and that's where
you're starting to learn about random
stuff campus life where the dorms are
doing little tours meeting with like an
advisor initially to kind of help put
your schedule together it's all that
normal [ __ ] to help an incoming freshman
why's your parents got to be there
uh is it hey okay hey can you just help
what i guess hey you can use your line
now i am a very cool guy
yeah yeah i'm a cool guy
yeah i'm a cool guy
but but in order to uh choose the people
who are fit to kind of orientate
incoming freshmen what they try to do is
they try to pull
like an even representation of campus
life so they're usually selecting people
from like a very vast type of a group of
organizations whether they be cultural
clubs sororities and fraternities to
blah blah blah blah blah yeah dance
teams martial arts blah blah just so
that there's kind of like a more
holistic representation of what's
possible therefore different incoming
freshmen might feel like they have
somebody to like lean on but behind the
formal stuff is when we just [ __ ] did
drugs and got [ __ ] up okay there it is
well here's here's some more that's
hillary kumar right here man from the
math team and the spelling bee team
but but also like when they're when they
were picking the people like they also
picked people that were like the most
fun usually or like uh you know had good
personalities and also some hotties they
picked a lot of hotties no go figure
she made it
that guy is a cool guy bro i'm a cool
guy
so you guys were a part of that group
imagine this this is also where a lot of
us for the first time did like ecstasy
yeah you know what i'm saying so it's
like in college so it's kind of like you
think you're a part of a student
orientation program trying to facilitate
shift from incoming freshmen and then
you end up embarking on one of the
craziest personal life adventures
yourself
thus bonding you to this group of people
you don't even give a [ __ ] about the
freshmen sometimes you're just like yo
that weekend was sick bro you know what
i mean uci sees this and they're like
we're going to cancel spot now
they know they know they are it's
because of our year that they had to
change the entire structure why yeah our
year went they said no to drugs
so so after ours because we had weekend
uh orientations they started doing the
the one day orientation so it wouldn't
get too crazy
damn that's too bad that's hilarious i
think you guys ruined it forever because
it really did sound like this fabled
like awesome thing well yeah it was all
about the training before right because
there was a semester of training before
the actual orientation and during that
that's when we all just partied together
it was like a bonding thing huh yeah and
there was this weird thing where in
order to make it feel like uh i guess
neutral you wouldn't disclose your
affiliations or your organizations in
the training some people would know but
you know it's like oh yeah obviously
we're part of the same you know
fraternity or whatever but you wouldn't
go in there and be like i'm part of this
it was just like humans on campus and
then you just like find your bonds find
your strengths find your differences
blah blah blah blah through the training
and then eventually at the end of the
training you'd be like oh you're a part
of this you're part of that and so i was
kind of interesting though he was so
interesting shut the [ __ ] up
go [ __ ] make some friends dude
i can't keep alienating him
you're a kappa sigma dude you were
rolling balls last night and i was
giving you a massage
my mom doesn't uh subscribe to you guys
right
[Music]
[Music]
you